ma femme a du crédit documentaire
réalisé par le journaliste français
Sébastien le belgic il est marié à une
chinoise tous deux sont installés à
Pékin et pendant un an il a donc choisi
de filmer son épouse au quotidien pour
mieux révéler l'impact du traçage
numérique dont font désormais l'objet
chaque chinois traçage qui là-bas vous
venez de le voir vise un objectif clair
en faire de bons ou de mauvais citoyens
de quoi bien sûr s'interroger sur les
dérives des nouveaux modes de
surveillance des individus et c'est ce
que nous allons faire maintenant sur ce
plateau de débat doc en compagnie de mes
invités en commençant par vous Anthony
Dufour bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste de l'Asie producteur et
c'est vous qui avez produit ce film
réalisé par Sébastien leveldic avec
votre société de production
Hikari on va bien sûr revenir sur les
conditions de ce film le tournage est
bien entendu le contenu de ce film que
nous venons de voir à l'instant et on va
le faire avec Jean Gabriel ganatcia
bienvenue à vous vous êtes professeur à
la Sorbonne université chercheur en
intelligence artificielle et ancien
président du comité d'éthique du CNRS
votre dernier livre s'intitule servitude
virtuel et il est édité aux éditions du
Seuil et puis enfin avec nous Olivier
teste bienvenue au lui était-ce quai
vous êtes journaliste spécialisé sur les
questions numériques chez nos confrères
de Télérama et auteur de ce livre état
d'urgence technologique publiée chez
premier parallèle en tenue Dufour on va
préciser d'emblée que ce film a déjà été
diffusé chez nos confrères de la RTBF en
Belgique également en Suisse francophone
avez-vous des nouvelles depuis de
Sébastien le Belgique le réalisateur de
ce film a-t-il eu des problèmes des
soucis avec la sécurité chinoise depuis
la diffusion de son film dans une partie
de l'Europe non non pas de souci ils
vont bien ils sont à Pékin
continue selon la même routine depuis
maintenant plus de deux ans puisqu'ils
peuvent quasiment pas bouger de Pékin en
raison des contraintes
énormes qui sont imposées aux habitants
de Pékin par le par le régime pour les
pour pour la question du covid mais ils
vont bien les personnages que vous voyez
dans le film ont parfois reçu la visite
de la police pour les inciter à ne plus
vraiment participer à ce genre de
programme mais pour le reste pour le
reste ils vont bien il y a pas eu de il
y a pas eu de conséquences on pense
aussi à la femme Lulu la femme du
réalisateur de ce documentaire elle n'a
pas non plus fait l'objet de de poursuit
de particulière à pas le tournage de ce
film non c'est évidemment plus
inquiétant pour les citoyens chinois qui
participent à nos films parce que eux
peuvent directement être impactés par le
système judiciaire chinois un
journaliste français risque d'expulsion
pour même si les choses se sont un peu
aggravées ces dernières ces dernières
années globalement c'est à peu près le
risque le risque comprendre le
documentaire est j'ai envie de dire
calibré c'est-à-dire que la parole de
lui n'est pas franchement hostile au
système qu'elle découvre elle lui trouve
aussi des mérites
et elles ne sont pas directement au
régime finalement et c'est un petit peu
la limite la ligne rouge à ne pas
franchir dans ce genre dans ce genre
d'exercice elle n'est pas franchie et
donc a priori il y a pas de raison que
le régime Vienne s'en prendre à elle on
va voir un tout premier extrait du film
sur le double digital chinois c'est
comme ça qu'on l'appelle dans ce film
tous les Chinois ont désormais un double
digital qui vit sa vie dans les serveurs
informatiques de Pékin
un double noté calibré jugé par les
ordinateurs du parti
[Musique]
pour les citoyens ça ressemble à un jeu
ou à un programme de fidélité
pour faire simple il va être difficile
de d'acheter un billet de train il va
être difficile de voyager à l'étranger
difficile d'inscrire vos enfants dans
les meilleures écoles vous devenez un
citoyen de seconde classe et donc c'est
certain un jeu mais un jeu machiavélique
parce qu'il a des conséquences directes
sur votre vie quotidienne comment sont
gérés les données par le pouvoir central
c'est pas très bien expliqué dans le
film est-ce que vous pouvez vous en dire
un petit peu plus alors on n'est pas au
cœur c'est vrai de des serveurs des
serveurs chinois ce qui ce que la Chine
a réussi à faire c'est à obtenir la
collaboration de l'ensemble des acteurs
du pays les employeurs les agents des
télécoms les grands réseaux de télécom
les tous les services informatiques les
les banques à chaque fois que vous
faites et surtout les les gafams Chinois
l'ensemble mais l'ensemble des actes de
la vie quotidienne est enregistré dans
un serveur le serveur de l'entreprise le
serveur de la banque etc ce qui fait la
force de la Chine c'est qu'à un moment
le pouvoir a un droit de regard sur
l'ensemble de ses serveurs et peut
interconnecter toutes ces données ski
logiquement n'arrive pas chez nous mais
ce qui est possible pour la Chine donc
je suis pas certain qu'il y a un grand
serveur central avec dans lequel sont
emmagasinés l'ensemble des données mais
il y a la possibilité à chaque moment
d'intervenir et de réussir à comprendre
le trajet d'une personne intellectuelle
physique commerciale sociale tout au
long de la journée est-ce que vous avez
envie de rajouter l'un ou l'autre
d'ailleurs quelque chose à ce qui vient
d'être dit et au documentaire que nous
venons de voir concernant la Chine vous
avez appris des choses dans documentaire
il y a des choses à compléter qu'on
aurait peut-être pas vu ou entendu dans
ce documentaire moi j'ai été frappé à la
question que vous avez posé vous avez
demandé si c'était une forme de
totalitarisme tel numérique telle que le
rêverait le pouvoir chinois moi ça me
frappe dans la mesure où c'est une sorte
de totalitarisme très mou et très
réconfortant quelque part c'est-à-dire
que le totalitarisme la définition qu'on
pourrait en donner c'est que c'est la
pénétration de la sphère intime par le
pouvoir c'est-à-dire le pouvoir s'arrose
tout à coup le droit de venir regarder
ce que vous faites chez vous ce que fait
exactement le pouvoir chinois dans la
mesure on a toujours son téléphone avec
soi peut-être chez eux encore plus chez
nous ça devient le espèce d'amulette
universel qu'on promène avec soi avec
comme finalité ce fameux compte social
et avec on est un bon un mauvais citoyen
un citoyen de première zone deuxième
zone 3e devant l'action la plus la plus
anodine je me sens il y a une scène dans
le dans le film où on les voit dans une
librairie avec des ouvrages de tisane
ping et
l'oeuvre la vie de chez ginking et le
réalisateur demande à sa femme est-ce
que tu penses que ça te rapporte des
points dans un coin de la tête on se
demande mais est-ce que c'est finalement
une vue de l'esprit est-ce que ça
pourrait pas se passer de cette façon là
et quand je dis que c'est un totaliste
un totalitarisme mou ou réconfortant
c'est qu'il y a cette idée qu'on sent
bien et qui est d'ailleurs explicité
c'est clairement dans le dans le
documentaire que tout ça et jamais
imposé finalement c'est à dire que cette
fabrique des bons et des mauvais
citoyens enfin surtout des bons se fait
avec l'assentiment la complicité de la
population qui n'y voit finalement pas
trop d'inconvénients elle voit même un
certain nombre d'avantages parce que
vous allez pouvoir partir en week-end et
loger dans un meilleur hôtel que si vous
êtes un citoyen de second rang et cette
idée il y en avait si vous avez
un mauvais compte social vous n'avez pas
accès aux parties communistes vous
n'avez pas accès à certaines
administrations vous n'avez pas accès à
certaines destinations il y a une
sanction immédiate aussi il y a une
sanction absolument absolument immédiate
mais je trouve ça assez frappant parce
que quand on dit totalitarisme
aujourd'hui et dans l'exception qu'on en
a il y a quand même cette idée que le
tolérique de teletarisme s'impose à nous
de manière assez brutale là ça se fait
finalement
sans friction quelque part et l'origine
fait davantage la promotion des des
qualités plutôt que de la menace c'est à
dire que devenir un décidant en Chine
c'est toujours un accident de parcours
on s'en rend pas compte on tombe en
dessous du seuil où on s'intéresse à une
question mais il y a pas un moment où
les médias vous ont avertir attention
vous intéressez pas tirer vous arrivez
des problèmes ne faites pas ça c'est
compliqué vous allez vous allez avoir il
y a une forme de naïveté du citoyen
chinois qui n'est pas forcément informé
des limites qu'il ne doit je dois pas
dépasser en général quand il est dépasse
il a pas forcément fait exprès et et ce
qui est pour ça que finalement il y a un
support général de la de la population
jusqu'au jour où l'accident survient et
il se retrouve dans la deuxième zone
qu'est-ce qui vous inspire cet exemple
chinois et tout d'abord au début on le
dit tout à fait clairement dans le film
c'est une infantilisation et ce côté jeu
et totalement présent deuxième chose je
ne pense pas que ce soit un
totalitarisme au sens où on pense au
grand totalitarisme du 20e siècle en
sens où on n'essaye pas de savoir ce que
les gens pensent et de les forcer à
penser d'une certaine façon non c'est
vraiment un espionnage de l'ensemble de
leur comportement alors ça rejoint
curieusement une idée qui vient d'un
Français Napoléon lorsqu'il était à
Sainte-Hélène et le mémoire le mémorial
de Las Cases l'évoque il avait l'idée
s'il revenait au pouvoir d'instituer un
corps d'espion de vertus qui
parcourterait tout l'Empire et qui
serait capable de noter les bonnes
actions de l'ensemble des sujets pour
les récompenser mais on a exactement la
même chose et sur du tété très difficile
de mettre en œuvre parce que vous êtes
très cher encore d'espions de vertus on
imagine tous les fonctionnaires puis on
irait pas été certain que ces
fonctionnaires cet été totalement note
tandis que là avec les prouesses de la
technologie voyons que tout ça est
réalisé de façon tout à fait
systématique alors évidemment lorsqu'on
voit ce type de documentaire cet exemple
chinois qui est en train de se dérouler
sous nos yeux la question qu'on se pose
c'est est-ce que ça va arriver chez nous
alors chez nous en Europe
en France dans le monde occidental
peut-être plus largement est-ce que
c'est déjà le cas
alors l'ensemble des technologies qu'on
peut qu'on voit dans le film sont
présentes chez nous c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a pas aujourd'hui une technologie
particulière qui donne un avantage
crucial au régime chinois toutes ces
technologies sont aujourd'hui non
seulement disséminées à travers le monde
mais beaucoup d'acteurs chinois
d'entreprises chinoises en font la
promotion à travers la France et à
travers l'Europe donc ils sont à la
limite dans une logique exportatrice de
leur savoir-faire c'est l'usage qui en
effet c'est la manière dont on va trier
les informations dont on va pouvoir les
utiliser qui fait finalement la
différence entre notre pays et la Chine
ce qui est frappant aussi c'est que on a
tendance à voir ce crédit social
une forme de deuil un peu exotisant on
se dit que ça vient de très loin voilà
ce serait très spécifique à la Chine et
ce serait un horizon très inquiétant
mais qu'on regarde d'un peu loin or
quand on refait l'historique un peu de
ce crédit social on se rend compte que
c'est une invention et je crois que le
film en fait mention c'est une invention
américaine en fait le Crédit social
c'est-à-dire que aux États-Unis sur le
bonus malus des sociétés de score de
crédit avec des sociétés qu'on appelle
des courtiers en données alors qui qui
sont un peu sous la surface ou pas
immédiatement visible qui font ça depuis
un peu après la Seconde Guerre mondiale
notamment où ça s'est généralisé avec la
grande distribution particulièrement
qui ont commencé à masser des quantités
très impressionnantes d'informations sur
les individus avec cette idée
d'attribuer à chacun un score qui va
conditionner ce que vous pouvez faire
dans la vie on sait que dans un pays
comme les États-Unis peuplés de
self-made évidemment la capacité
d'emprunt est un marqueur
particulièrement important je trouve que
c'est important de de fin de refaire
cette chronologie un peu à l'envers pour
se rendre compte que finalement ce
crédit social à la chinoise ne vient pas
de nulle part et il vient même plutôt du
monde occidental
oui je crois qu'il faut effectivement
insister là-dessus il existe des formes
de notation dans nos sociétés par
exemple dans les banques vous avez une
notation qui permet de vous attribuer un
crédit de même il y a une autre notation
à laquelle on ne pense pas mais le
permis à point par exemple c'est une
forme de notation alors ce qui est
particulier c'est tout le monde tout le
monde dans tout le monde voilà c'est
quelque chose de tout à fait classique
ce qui est particulier c'est
effectivement l'usage des technologies
pour le faire à très grande échelle ça a
commencé dans des villes et maintenant
on sent que ça va se généraliser à
l'ensemble de la Chine mais je crois
qu'il faut ça a été très clairement dit
dans le film
il faut bien se souvenir que ça a
commencé lorsque la Chine a voulu
s'ouvrir au monde occidental et à ce
moment-là elle avait un souci parce que
les hommes d'affaires qui rencontraient
des Chinois n'étaient pas capables de
savoir quel était le sérieux la
crédibilité des personnes et c'est pour
ça que la Chine a voulu mettre en place
un score et puis ensuite elle a
généralisé ce score à ensemble de la
population avec cette deuxième idée
alors là qui est peut-être plus
proprement chinois c'est cette idée
d'harmonie de la de la société c'est à
dire qu'une bonne société c'est une
société à laquelle il y a un équilibre
entre l'ensemble des composantes de la
société
Antony Dufour autrement dit bon la
technologie elle existe c'est à peu près
la même pour tout le monde on y
reviendra parce que c'est un c'est un
énorme marché commercial ces
technologies c'est juste l'utilisation
qu'on entend
bien entendu
il y a peut-être un tout petit point à
l'intérieur du film avec lequel je ne
suis pas d'accord c'est quand on laisse
entendre que la Chine a 20 ans d'avance
sur les technologies non elle n'a pas 20
ans d'avance sur les technologies c'est
de l'intelligence artificielle appliquée
sur des données
issues de capteurs et on est capable de
mettre ça en œuvre depuis très longtemps
nous avions d'ailleurs un champion de la
reconnaissance faciale en France a été
revendu à une
autre société donc nous avons
effectivement en Europe
les entreprises qui ont la capacité de
mettre au point ces différences
technologies simplement il y a des
réticences extrêmement fortes dans dans
nos pays on va voir un deuxième extrait
du film il est question des caméras de
surveillance et c'est la base de
beaucoup de choses notamment de cette
fameuse reconnaissance faciale
elle se généralise en Chine dès le début
des années 2000
surveillance du domicile des entreprises
des magasins il y en a partout dans les
vins villes les plus équipées au monde
de caméras de surveillance 18 sont
chinoises
chunching 31 millions d'habitants compte
une caméra pour 6 habitants
Shanghai 26 millions une pour 9 en
comparaison Nice la ville française la
plus équipée compte une caméra pour 130
habitants
une société sous surveillance dont il
est quasiment impossible de se
soustraire dans les yeux du Big Brother
chinois sont partout
alors les chiffres c'était ici donne
quelques pulls vertiges c'est vrai mais
ça permet de bien mesurer le
développement de ces caméras et de cette
vidéo surveillance c'est la base de tout
et c'est ce qui amène à la fameuse
reconnaissance faciale la reconnaissance
faciale c'est la véritable nouveauté de
cette fin de première partie du siècle
et l'intelligence artificielle qui va
permettre d'adopter des technologies
prédictives qui permettent de savoir que
dans tel quartier on voit plus de gens
que d'habitude avec un sac à dos donc ça
veut dire quelque chose il est en train
de se masser quelque chose ou au
contraire on voit moins de voitures ou
moins de d'enfants passé que d'habitude
ça veut aussi dire qu'il se passe
quelque chose mais là encore sont des
technologies qui semblent fascinantes et
mon Dieu que peuvent faire les Chinois
avec ça mais à Valenciennes ou à Nice on
utilise les mêmes technologies
aujourd'hui qui sont d'ailleurs des des
exportations chinoises ce sont les
Chinois qui les ont implantés dans ces
villes donc on est face à
des caméras qui dans de nombreux
explosent un usage dont le nombre expose
mais c'est c'est toute l'utilisation
qu'on va en faire et toutes les limites
aux utilisations qu'on va pouvoir en
faire qui la différence entre ce qui se
passe en Chine et ce qui pourra se
passer chez nous la reconnaissance
faciale en France on n'y a pas le droit
aujourd'hui c'est interdit la
reconnaissance faciale sauf dans
certains cas à posterodie par les
services de police là aussi on peut se
poser la question est-ce que ça risque
d'arriver chez nous ce système de
reconnaissance faciale pour l'instant il
faut avoir
l'autorisation de des personnes pour le
faire on n'y a pas le droit ça n'empêche
pas que certaines municipalités aux
collectivités ont un peu tenté leur
chance je me souviens par exemple à Nice
et à Marseille la région Sud avait tenté
d'installer des portiques de
reconnaissance faciale à l'entrée de
deux lycées Nice et à Marseille
expérimentation donc les portiques qui
avaient été installée l'expérimentation
a finalement été interdite par le
tribunal administratif et par la CNIL
donc la Commission Nationale
Informatique et Liberté qui est un peu
le gendarme de la vie privée en France
donc on sent qu'il y a à la fois une
offre industrielle très importante et
notamment parce qu'il y a plein
d'entreprises chinoises qui ont
totalement pénétré le marché français
aujourd'hui si vous vous baladez dans la
rue regardez curiosité la marque des
caméras il y a une chance sur deux pour
que les caméras soient de marque exigen
qui est une société chinoise qui par
ailleurs et blacklisté aux États-Unis
parce que elle aide la Chine dans la
traque des Ouigours cette minorité
musulmane
et à l'équipe très grande majorité des
collectivités des collectivités en
France cette offre industrielle d'un
côté et il y a une demande politique
très forte de l'autre il aura échappé à
personne qu'en plus on a les Jeux
Olympiques à Paris en 2024 et qu'à cette
occasion là les grands événements
sportifs sont toujours des grands
moments de normalisation de ce type de
technologie comme leçon d'ailleurs aussi
les crises sanitaires donc ça aide pas
on a un peu des effets cumulatifs et on
sait que à l'approche des JO il y a une
poussée politique et industrielle très
très forte pour expérimenter et définir
un cadre légal pour utiliser cette
technologie
je crois que ces technologies sont à la
convergence de trois types de d'outils
d'abord il y a des caméras des
captations d'information ensuite il y a
la fusion de tout un tas d'informations
qui permettent de suivre en direct d'une
caméra de montre le parcours d'une
personne et puis enfin il y a
l'interprétation avec des techniques
d'intelligence artificielle de ce qu'il
y a sur la caméra alors ça peut être la
reconnaissance faciale c'est-à-dire
savoir quel est l'identité de la
personne et puis ça peut être aussi la
reconstration du comportement savoir
qu'il a traversé savoir qu'il a jeter un
papier par terre etc alors ces
technologies on est dans le domaine de
l'intelligence on est dans le domaine de
l'intelligence artificielle cette
technologie doivent être doivent-elles
nous inquiéter
partiellement car nous avons des
applications de la reconnaissance
faciale qui sont parfaitement acceptées
aujourd'hui par exemple lorsque vous
allez dans un aéroport en France vous
passez dans le système paraphe et là on
est capable avec des techniques de
reconnaissance faciale de
s'assurer que vous êtes bien le
détenteur du passeport que vous
présentez donc ça c'est de
l'identification et ça pose c'est de la
l'authentification pardon et ça pose pas
de problème ce qui pose problème c'est
l'identification c'est le fait que dans
la rue vous vous promenez avec une
personne et puis on est capable
automatiquement de savoir que vous étiez
à tel endroit à telle heure avec telle
personne ça c'est beaucoup plus gênant
et puis un troisième aspect encore plus
gênant qui est utilisé en Chine c'est la
reconnaissance automatique par exemple
de l'ethnie ou la catégorisation savoir
que c'est un homme une femme en Chine je
crois qu'on a essayé de détecter les
Ouigours de façon automatique ce qui
pose ce qui pose beaucoup de problèmes
alors bien sûr aujourd'hui les questions
puisque vous en parlez cette minorité
musulmane donc que vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure fait l'objet d'une surveillance
toute particulière avec des moyens tout
particulier 10 milliards de dollars pour
cette seule province chinoise sont
consacrées au domaine qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui donc bien sûr ce qu'il faut
c'est avoir une réflexion sur parmi
l'ensemble de ces technologies ce qui
est acceptable ce qui est positif parce
que vous voyez que on est des caméras
par exemple dans les parkings et que on
détecte des comportements agressifs mais
peut-être pas totalement négatif il faut
pas le condamner a priori il y a des
situations difficiles et puis ce qui est
inacceptable parce que nous avons
l'impression que ça va à l'encontre de
nos valeurs de la dignité des individus
ça je crois que ça doit nous conduire à
une réflexion d'ensemble de l'ensemble
de la société à partir de ces outils
le raisonnement sur ce que vous venez de
nous dire est-ce que le droit français
pourrait distinguer ce qui est positif
ou négatif c'est compliqué vous vous
avez vous avez dit quelque part je l'ai
lu en préparant ce dossier notre droit
court après la technologie oui parce
qu'aujourd'hui
panel de citoyens d'experts qui seraient
à même de déterminer quels usages comme
les disais Jean-Gabriel serait vertueux
et lesquels ne le seraient pas après la
difficulté c'est qu'aujourd'hui on se
rend compte et moi pour travailler sur
la question de manière assez assidue
quand vous essayez d'obtenir des
informations sur les expérimentations
qui sont menées on peut pas dire que ce
soit d'une transparence absolue souvent
parce que ce sont des usages policiers
et que usages policiers se faisant à
titre expérimental se font un peu sous
le radar ce qui est pas non plus à
construire la confiance autour de ces
voulaient ajouter quelque chose oui on a
parlé d'expérimentation les
municipalités se sont transformées en
showroom sécuritaire c'est ce que vous
avez dit aussi quelque part oui je
voudrais insister sur la notion
d'expérimentation je crois que il est
vraiment essentiel que l'on puisse avec
ces technologies arriver à savoir
exactement quels sont les conséquences
les modes d'appropriation de ces
technologies et si la législation est
trop rigide elle va empêcher toute forme
d'expérimentation il faudrait donner je
crois un statut très particulier à ces
expérimentations pour que ensuite on
puisse avoir des études d'impact
extrêmement clairs fondées sur des
résultats empiriques ça me semble très
très important parce que sinon
effectivement on risque d'avoir des
craintes qui sont non fondées c'est
craintes étant non fondées on va
empêcher de développer un certain nombre
de technologie et puis ensuite une fois
que des besoins se font jour à ce moment
on va acheter ces technologies à
l'étranger pour faire venir
des dispositifs sans en avoir aucunement
la maîtrise et il me semble que du point
de vue français et européen ce serait
tout à fait dommageable alors juste une
parenthèse c'est s'expirementations dont
on parle dans les villes que vous avez
citées c'est-à-dire Valenciennes Nice
notamment qui est très en pointe en tout
cas c'est la volonté de son son mais
Christian Estrosi dans ce domaine de la
de la de la reconnaissance faciale ça se
fait avec du matériel français où ça se
fait avec du matériel chinois ou
américain je dis ça parce que à
Valenciennes c'est way way
grand opérateur téléphonique chinois qui
a offert plus de 200 caméra pas à la
municipalité pour pour en faire un
showroom finalement on le fait pas avec
du matériel français aujourd'hui non on
le fait très peu avec du matériel
français ça veut pas dire que ça
n'existe pas vous l'avez dit à
Valenciennes c'est une convention avec
avec Huawei quand Nice et Marseille ont
déployé ses portiques de reconnaissance
faciale à l'entrée des lycées c'est avec
l'américain Cisco on a tout un tas
d'autres exemples comme ça quand Nice
essaye la reconnaissance faciale pendant
le carnaval avec une expérimentation
dont il y aurait beaucoup à dire
d'ailleurs sur le plan méthodologique
parce que derrière on nous présente des
résultats de république bananière qui en
fait n'indique rien mais permettent de
construire un discours politique sur une
supposée efficacité à 100% de ces
technologies à ce moment-là c'est un
logiciel israélien mais qui est mis en
oeuvre avec un intégrateur monégasque
donc on noie un peu le poisson on met
des couches comme ça de de différents
pays de différents produits qui viennent
de différents endroits après je pense
pas que le débat de se porter uniquement
sur la souveraineté technologique c'est
à dire est-ce que la spatiale par
exemple entreprises françaises
présenteraient moins de danger ou
seraient mécaniquement plus vertueuse
que la reconnaissance faciale mise en
oeuvre par des sociétés chinoises je ne
le crois pas peut-être les poser encore
plus de questions quand elle est mise en
oeuvre par des sociétés chinoises parce
qu'on aurait se poser en tant que
société occidentale la question de
savoir est-ce qu'on doit cautionner les
pratiques de société comme exigent qui
sont complices de ce génocide culturel
qui est perpétré contre les wigos une
résolution qui a été votée très
récemment ici même à l'Assemblée sur le
caractère génocidaire de de ce qui est
de la répression contre les régimes
chinois contre les ouégos et donc dans
ces conditions là effectivement le le
fait qu'on s'équipe avec du matériel
chinois pose davantage question mais je
pense qu'il faut définir une éthique
générale de l'utilisation de ces
technologies indépendamment de la nature
ou de la nationalité des équipements
vous disiez tout à l'heure il y a il
existe sans doute une tentation du côté
de la CNIL qui contrôle évidemment les
choses chez nous en France de valider
une opération de contrôle spatiale à
l'occasion des Jeux olympiques de 2024
la décision n'est pas prise mais
semble-t-il il y aurait une tentation un
d'essayer de le faire et j'ai vu qu'il y
avait un certain nombre d'entreprises
françaises qui étaient prêtes à répondre
à des appels d'offres en la matière Atos
d'ao-système Capgemini ils ont les
moyens de battre leur concurrents
chinois et américains dans ce domaine
aujourd'hui parce que moi mon petit ma
petite routine tous les deux ans
consiste à aller au salon millipol Parc
des Expositions de Villepinte qui est le
grand raout des industriels de la
sécurité et ça fait quelques années
qu'on voit monter petite musique de la
biométrie de l'identification des
personnes on sent bien que le visage et
la nouvelle frontière de la vie privée
ça c'est irréfutable et on a des
entreprises françaises on a des
champions de la biométrie une entreprise
comme
idemia une entreprise comme Thalès
aujourd'hui qui a racheté j'ai mal tôt
donc c'est on a des leaders
internationaux sur la biométrie le
problème c'est que ces acteurs là disent
aujourd'hui le cadre européen avec
notamment le règlement général sur la
protection des données le fait que les
législations dans les différents pays
sont pas très clairs l'Union européenne
est en train de plancher sur un
règlement sur l'intelligence
artificielle tout ça leur offre
évidemment des coûts moins franches que
des entreprises chinoises qui elles ont
toute l'attitude pour entraîner leurs
algorithmes avec évidemment une
population
beaucoup plus consentante par la force
des choses
au vu des chiffres on y met pas tout à
fait les mêmes moyens en matière de
recherche concernant l'intelligence
artificielle j'ai vu que les Chinois
avaient décidé l'an dernier de mettre 60
milliards de dollars un par an dans ce
dans ce domaine et en Europe c'est 20
milliards d'euros donc on mesure quand
même une certaine différence on évoquait
peut-être les bénéfices qu'on pourrait
tirer de ces surveillances de masse de
ces dispositifs de de surveillance de
deux masse et l'argument numéro 1 qui
est mis en avant y compris dans les
municipalités françaises qui qui testent
ces systèmes aujourd'hui c'est la
sécurité la sécurité des citoyens ça
c'est tout de même un argument en faveur
de de la surveillance de deux masse
alors c'est un argument qui est aussi
évoqué en Chine mais pas seulement
aujourd'hui quand vous voulez prendre
l'avion à Pékin vous pouvez simplement
vous présenter à l'aéroport et et votre
tête c'est votre carte d'embarquement on
voit une petite scène amusante dans le
documentaire quand Lulu souhaite
d'acheter une boisson dans le métro le
distributeur de boissons la reconnaît
donc on paye pas le boum la boisson sort
c'est extrêmement pratique et finalement
c'est sur ces vertus pratiques sur
attrayantes facilitante que que le
système est vendu au chinois ça va vous
aider vous allez plus que dans les vendu
aussi en France
dans sa ville à Nice c'est pour
renforcer la sécurité oui c'est pas
l'aspect ludique pour est-ce qu'on
pratique c'est vraiment l'aspect
sécuritaire alors est-ce qu'on obtient
des résultats c'était ma question en
matière sécurité avec de tels systèmes
où est-ce qu'on peut avoir de réel
espoir d'en obtenir dans les années qui
viennent c'est bien là où le bât blesse
parce que il n'y a pas de preuve
évidente que on assure mieux la sécurité
avec ce type de dispositif c'est pour ça
je crois qu'il faut absolument que l'on
ait des expérimentations transparentes
grandeur nature avec un statut
particulier sur l'expérimentation et
puis ensuite être capable de revenir en
arrière et avoir la possibilité de
lorsque on voit que les orientation soit
et problématique pour le citoyen soit
parce qu'elle n'est pas efficace de ne
pas mettre en oeuvre les différents
dispositifs je crois que c'est vraiment
là que le point essentiel comme on l'a
dit tout à l'heure comme on l'a dit
olivieres on a en France une tradition
dans ces secteurs-là extrêmement fortes
idemia c'est une française mais au
départ c'était une société française
Thalès etc sont des sociétés qui ont de
très très bons résultats dans ces
domaines là mais ensuite il y a entre
l'aspect technologique de reconnaissance
faciale et puis la mise en oeuvre en
situation une marche extrêmement grande
et je crois que c'est ça qu'il faut
essayer de sur quoi il faut essayer de
réfléchir parce que on se demande là à
l'instant T savoir quel serait
l'efficacité de d'outils de
reconnaissance faciale de détection des
comportements suspects etc je
rappellerai quand même que ça fait 10
ans que au cours des comptes demande au
législateur à la puissance publique de
prouver l'efficacité de la vidéo
surveillance donc la vidéo surveillance
à l'ancienne si je veux dire celle dont
on équipe les municipalités depuis
maintenant le milieu des années 90 et
aujourd'hui on a toujours pas d'étude
sérieuse qui nous permet d'affirmer que
la vidéo surveillance a une véritable
utilité dans la résolution des affaires
criminelles alors ce qu'on dit ce que je
disais tout à l'heure depuis 2012 seul
la reconnaissance a postériori et
permise notamment par la police à l'aide
du fichier de traitement des antécédents
judiciaires le Tagi alors d'après un
rapport de l'Assemblée nationale qui a
été publié en 2018 ce fichier compterait
déjà plus de 18 millions de personnes
dont 8 millions avec photos
ça veut dire que les choses sont tout de
même en cours et que peut-être la
sécurité nationale la police en
l'occurrence obtient un certain nombre
de résultats
a postériori on sent bien sur toute la
pression sur l'utilisation de ces outils
qu'aujourd'hui le Tage quand vous allez
avoir un contrôle de police et on a de
plus en plus d'histoire qui remontent
comme ça j'ai même vu la semaine
dernière un reportage sur M6 on le
voyait
ses propres yeux c'est à dire vous avez
un contrôle de police et au moment du
contrôle de police vous avez un des
fonctionnaires qui
passent prendre une photo de l'individu
qui était en train de contrôler le Pass
à la moulinette du TAS donc le fichier
ça me fait chier que j'ai évoqué à
l'instant mise en cause qui est le seul
cadre effectivement d'emploi aujourd'hui
de la reconnaissance faciale par les
forces de police pour
parce que les citoyens ou ceux qui ont
envie de d'éviter le système trouve une
solution vous avez vu cet artiste dans
le dans le documentaire voilà qui trouve
un moyen d'éviter les innombrables
caméras de surveillance dans son
quartier alors c'est un c'est un peu
extrême mais il est encore possible
aujourd'hui pour des militants notamment
d'usine Yang d'aller s'immoler par le
feu devant la porte de la Cité Interdite
donc ils arrivent à passer aujourd'hui
entrer sur la cité sur la place c'est
plus compliqué que entrer dans un
aéroport en France vous avez un nombre
de contrôle absolument dingue on arrive
encore à passer ce qui veut dire que
finalement à partir du moment où les
règles du jeu sont connues ou cette
reconnaissance faciale devient l'alpha
et l'oméga de la sécurité on trouvera
toujours un moyen d'éviter
bien ce sera le mot de la fin Anthony
Dufour merci vraiment à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à cette émission
aujourd'hui sur la base du documentaire
que vous avez produit Anthony Dufour ma
femme a du crédit c'était son titre vos
réactions ça sera sur hashtag des Badoc
sur Twitter j'imagine que elles ne vont
pas manquer nos invités
pourront réagir à ce que seront
d'ailleurs vos réactions à la suite de
notre émission grand merci également à
Selma Sally qui comme à l'accoutumée m'a
aidé à préparer cette émission je vous
donne rendez-vous pour un autre débat
doc ça sera la même place à la même
heure et bien sûr toujours avec son
documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]